you turn down Sex in the City you you
will no I said yes I shot the pilot and
then I panicked and you decided I'm not
going to do it you told HBO that you
would give them a deal where you would
produce a bunch of movies and be in
movies and things for them if they just
let you out of Sex in the City and not
go ahead with you in the after that
that's what I was going to offer I went
to my agents and I was like I feel like
maybe I shouldn't be doing a television
series and so they said why because
television you felt hey I'm do I have a
movie career what am I doing television
before I just got panicked about being
like locked locked in and um in my head
it was just
it was just like the same thing over and
over again and like somebody had
put me in a straight jacket in in theory
so I went to Kevin euvane my agent of I
don't even know how many years now and
um I explained this and he said well
let's meet with the head of the TV
Department who's This brilliant guy and
he was like well what do you want and I
was like why don't we just offer them
I'll work for free for them for a year
ago what a businesswoman right don't ask
her because I felt like I had committed
to times with them was the pilot good it
was excellent did you watch it I hadn't
even I hadn't seen the pilot when this
happened because somebody stopped me on
the street a woman stopped me on the
street she was like Hey Sarah Jessica
how are you I was like great she's like
I saw your show I love it I was like
what show and she was like didn't you do
a show and I was like on what show and
she said sexy I was like oh my God yeah
I did oh they'd already put it on no she
had gotten a DVD or a tape of it and I
was like oh I haven't seen it she was
like it's great you should see and I was
like yeah I probably should see it so
then I panicked because you said I'm
gonna be stuck on TV I have other things
I want to do yeah so you say to HBO
theater I want to do a movie right I'll
work in the HBO cafeteria but anything
but uh this movie yes and so then I then
I met I met with them and they were like
what scares you and I said I'm I'm
scared of doing the same thing I'm
scared of routine and they said
this is HBO we don't we don't work like
that you you know we don't have to
answer to advertising dollars you know
if you if you get a movie you want we'll
figure it out we'll figure out the
shooting schedule if you get a play that
you want to do we'll figure it out we
we're counter programming at the time
right we're on in the summer everybody
else is on in the fall you know we can
shoot anytime
give it a chance and we they brought in
Barry Johnson who was a producer I did
Miami Rhapsody with who I loved right I
walked to the set from the apartment the
first day it was two blocks from my
house day one of shooting the first
season and we're doing a scene in a
dressing room
and I never look back and there wasn't a
single day on that set that I didn't
want to be there not one
single day
oh